but today I have to give you credit you
had a great thought while we were
talking about Russell Wilson's
appearance on Jimmy Fallon The Tonight
Show when this question just kind of
curiously came up about him having the
best contract in NFL history that felt
like a plant to you and I think you may
be right and I feel like maybe Russell
Wilson is trying to send the Seahawks a
message that now is the time to make him
the highest-paid player in the NFL not
one year two years three years from now
Yeah right he wants to get a go and get
it going now I mean Seattle if they're
smart they'd get it going now - just to
you know hey shave off a few million
dollars per year on the contract instead
of what Russell Wilson going out in 2019
and Oh once again having one of the best
seasons out of any quarterback in
football that's what he's done just
about every year here in recent history
so the price number is only gonna go up
especially if the team continues to
improve like it did last year and looks
like it's going to so I think from those
that standpoint it makes a lot of sense
but yes I mean as I understand anything
like that usually somebody for Jimmy
Fallon comes in and talks to the the
handlers or the agent whoever's there
with Russell Wilson they talk about
facts or things that are going on in the
life and I just think it's probably one
of those things where his agent was like
well yeah and you know hey there's a
chance Russell could be the highest-paid
quarter player in the history of the NFL
and they're like oh yeah sure that
sounds like a good question we'll write
that down just seemed like it was the
setup all along yeah and really we know
that that title is temporary you're only
going to be the highest-paid player in
football for a year or two maybe if
you're lucky three and if it's Russell
Wilson now superseding Aaron Rodgers
he's gonna hold that title probably
until Patrick mahomes does his next
contract but still you you get a chance
to at least be for some window of time
the highest-paid player in the history
of the NFL and it's not a bad thing it's
a good thing it means you've got a great
contract and I think the Seahawks would
be smart to get him to 33 points 6
million per year superseding Aaron
Rodgers 33 point 5 million per year now
because it's only gonna get more
expensive and Chris think about this
let's say he would play it out let's say
he would go franchise tag 2020 France
Tagg 2021 the seahawks let him hit the
market in 2022 instead of paying 52
million what do you think he makes per
year on the open market
oh my gosh I would think somebody
somebody signs them - all were desperate
we need a guy like this to come into our
organization and jumpstart everything I
mean I mean at that point I don't even
know what it would be 40 million a year
probably right something along those
lines with three years down the road I
would think that's gonna be top
quarterback tier type of money maybe
more than 40 million I mean we've never
seen anything like that and yes he'll be
33 at the time but for quarterbacks
it doesn't matter right if anything I'll
get better as you get older as long as
you still have your physical skills you
are at the point where your brain has
developed through all the reps
everything you've seen everything you've
studied to the point where the game
slows down even more the game is easier
and if he still has his uncanny physical
skills as the game slows down even more
he's gonna be even more effective as he
gets older there's this weird sense
though Chris that he's that he's
overrated that he's not as good as
people think that he can't do it all
like a Tom Brady or and Aaron Rodgers
can do I think he can do it all and I
think the fact that he stays healthy
that he's mobile that he gets out of
pocket he throws on the run he throws
accurately he can kill you with his legs
if he has to I think he's underrated if
anything I agree I think he is
phenomenal he is without question one of
the three best quarterbacks in football
I mean his all-time quarterback rating
and not that I hold everything true to
stats but there is some truth to stats
he's second all-time in the all-time
quarterback rating
I mean he's almost a three full points
above number three which is Drew Brees
that's how special russell wilson has
been all they've done is win since he's
been there they've been to two Super
Bowls one one of them I mean if you're
talking about rewarding guys for acting
appropriately and being leaders in the
face of your franchise damn nobody fits
that mold better than Russell Wilson I
mean he's just been mr. model sis and so
much of a model citizen and such a good
guy that it actually is seems like it
annoys people and especially in Seattle
like he's a goody two-shoes which I
understand he comes out that
what comes off that way a little bit go
Hawks are a little political but he
doesn't give a dim he's up he's with you
know upstanding is what what do I want
to say is his image as a player as a
person it's it's flawless and I think he
needs to be rewarded for that a little
bit too yeah some of the guys that used
to be on the Seahawks would mock him
behind his back right the go Hawks thing
they do it in a high-pitched voice and
and that you know and that's the thing
it was kind of a rough-and-tumble crowd
and then Russell Wilson comes in and
they viewed him as management not as one
of them they've always had that
resentment that's why they're reshaping
the roster with him as the centerpiece
of the team well you know what if that's
what you're doing you better pay the
centerpiece accordingly that's right
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports